optic battle pot is a competitive
networked game that makes extensive use
of three degree-of-freedom force
feedback and six degree-of-freedom input
in a new twist on a classic game players
interact both graphically in physic
employing a variety of haptic attacks
revive her victory the battle pong
earlier the game makes use of the
sensible phantom optic display the
devices have to complete that
capabilities are used to simulate
contact with the ball allowing a tight
integration between the players
movements and the game's physical
simulation
you
when a player comes in contact with a
haptic mine placed by his opponent he is
subject to one of several haptic attacks
one of the more exciting attacks is the
remote operation paddle which allows a
player to impart forces directly on his
opponents phantom this true physical
interaction between players similar to a
virtual handshake unlike anything
available in standard video games in god
mode players fire rockets at each other
with a weapon reminiscent of
first-person shooter games the haptic
device is used to render recoil from the
gun and the Rockets impact divorce
haptic battle pong simulates both linear
and rotational velocity allowing players
to play spin on the ball which affects
its trajectory and its response to
collisions here a player places enough
backspin on the ball to bring it back to
his own side of the court
you